five four three two one zero it was an
historic moment for India an unmanned
spacecraft bound for the moon
successfully launched in July after a
previous attempt was called off due to
technical problems Chand Ryan - which
means moon craft in ancient Sanskrit has
spent the last few weeks travelling
towards the south of the moon on Monday
the landing robot vikram separated from
the craft ahead of its plan touchdown if
successful India will become only the
fourth country in the world to have
achieved a controlled soft landing its
previous mission in 2008 ended with the
spacecraft probe intentionally crashing
into the moon the landing site this time
is around 600 kilometers from the Lunar
South Pole an unexplored section of the
moon after landing Vikram will release
India's first lunar rover onto the
surface it may be small but it carries
instruments that will measure among
other things water deposits scientists
know they exist
thanks to India's 2008 mission which
maps the moon's surface from orbit
there's a lot riding on this 126 million
euro endeavor not only does India hope
to advance the world's understanding of
the moon it also wants to prove how
advanced it is in space technology
you